upcoming election I know you're very
involved are you feeling any one way or
the other are you just nervous like
everybody else like all of us are just
thinking and in addition to covid and
everything else the idea that this
election is going to happen in weeks is
terrifying just terrifying I find yeah
and I and I and I track it like second
by second like I am tweeting I am
watching I am
stressing uh lesie decided like she just
Di in and checks every few days I check
minute by minute she looks so healthy
she looks like she's regenerating like
you know her skin she's like Millie
Bobby Brown I look like a wartime
president I'm just
aging you look like Franklin Roosevelt
in
1945 seconds before he died
exactly minutes before his death but I'm
hopeful that there's enough people in
the country who have realized that the
experiment was a mistake the experiment
to get that guy probably wasn't a good
idea maybe maybe that The Apprentice guy
can't run the country and that it's a
simple decision I mean we debate about a
lot of things but it seems kind of
simple at this point I think uh I think
what we should do is take a break from
having a TV host yes the president with
no uh experience uh um you know with the
electorate and then and maybe a term or
two down the line someone like me would
be ready the country would be ready
again I think if you don't get a haircut
till then and then you you get your own
little
swoop then I think then we're all for it
I get all the Trump people will be like
he kind of reminds me if by then I'll
have swirled it
around yeah I'm excited about it and I
I'm glad that I have your support still
very worried about your hoarding uh I
just want to say that before before we
go you've got to clean that place
up I love that so many people make an
effort to clean up the space behind them
you've done nothing you've done nothing
I've got nothing I just you were like
well time to go talk to Conan I guess
I'll just go in this room I I was
so bored the other night that I went on
eBay and I bought a autographed Gypsy
play Bell autograph by Patty Leone oh
there you go well how much can I ask I
you know what I don't I don't have that
information in front of me but I may not
have even looked I may have just clicked
it was one of those nights you know like
sometimes you're just like don't know
what I'm going to do right now I don't
know how I'm going to get to sleep I
wonder what signs play bills are on
eBay well make sure I get the word out
here uh the king of Staten Island now
available on Blu-ray everyone still has
Blu-ray right you still got that Blu-ray
who doesn't have a Blu-ray right now
everyone's got a Blu-ray it's a hot new
technology also you can jam this into a
CD player from the 70s and it will kind
of work yeah that's a guarantee the
extras the extras will work yes uh Jud
so nice to talk to you I I can't I can't
wait seriously I I honestly can't wait
till uh we get to be in this theater
together again with some funny people
and have a real show with humans that
would be such a blast we will be back
they can't stop us we shall return all
right Jud appau thank you and I bow to
you I bow to
[Laughter]
you